or en temps normal on ne fait rien je me
suis d'horaires s'était passé les
téléspectateurs qui l'ont rejoint lille
et 19h46 jouer et je vais je suis en
mesure de tout vous expliquer évidemment
on va vous expliquer sans voir on va
revoir les faits et j'aurai une
proposition à vous faire très bien si
vous voulez dans un instant ouais je
vous proposerai je sens le truc hein clc
et ça s'est passé c'est le chocolat
jusqu'à quand notre parti est vrai alors
n attendez vous allez voir on ne sait
pas si vous vous le proposez mais nous
l'exigeons voit tout et nous exigeons la
travée les travaux et je n'en peux plus
si on peut aider mais vous n'êtes pas
parce que vous êtes des syndicats
[Applaudissements]
ne m'en parlez dans un instant on va
revoir ce qui s'est passé parce que vous
le voyez
malheureusement dans ce look à gué
chocolat game 16ème round
on a perdu une personne âgée s'arrange
en plastique est encore là j'ai voulu
être comme je devais aller voir le
conducteur de l'émission et boire ce
qu'on allait faire après j'ai pas pu
voir la séquence a vu partir très vite
évidemment on va revoir ce qui s'est
passé par barcelone va s'en passer
regardons ce n'était pas ces gens-là cap
sinon au début
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une piqûre
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
ce
tu me plait merci à tous pour le moment
là où la louper on peut avoir hissé
belge isabelle a été bonne
ouais
[Rires]
m